thanks for joining us America of Fresno
California rubens on the line a Ruben
how are you hey mr. Ramsey I'm doing
great are you doing better than I
deserve what's up yeah yeah you know the
reason I was calling I had a question
recently I received $70,000 about 8
months ago and I got put into a
nine-month CD and currently right now
I'm just in the mix of my family wanting
me to you know win them you know $10,000
to take care of their debt and etc and
you know I want this money to you know
work for me in a way so I wanted to see
you know what would be the best options
to you know have that money work for me
instead of you know blowing it and eight
months like you know usually when people
win a lottery you know they're broke you
won the lottery
oh no I'm just no doubt the reference
you know where did you ever money um I
got a car I got an accident and that was
the money that I received from a
settlement
okay so you got $70,000 are you are you
in you were injured I assume yes are you
okay now yes I'm okay to you and my
sister was part of it too so it was a B
it's a slmb between us okay so she got
seventy thousand as well yeah were
seventy thousand between us two so that
was the amount that we got for that so
you have 35 and she has 35 correct and
you're how old I am currently 23 and
she's 18 okay all right are you guys in
school she's just about to graduate high
school this year and I'm currently a
junior in college right now and working
part-time and how are you paying for
college I am receiving financial
assistance and that pays for everything
um for the majority yes it's been
covering for the most of it
I mean I've stayed locally so it hasn't
been too expensive so you're doing
Community College or State College State
okay because I know Community College's
California free or not they're not free
they're furnished paid for by the state
oh yeah no I'm at university okay
and so but this is being paid for you're
getting the assistant
because of your family's financial
situation or what exactly my family's um
just uh you know growth income it's just
wanting to borrow money again um just
you know my family you know since they
know that this is the money we have that
you know they need they want us as
assistants to pay off their dead and you
know my sisters wanting to buy a new car
and you know this is something that you
know I want you know to work for the
long run you know and so what I would do
I mean I don't know why you're do to
give is it your parents are asking for
some of the money yet that's very hard
for you it 23 years old and they're
trying to make money off of this okay um
well I think you at your first
obligation is to make sure you get
through college and your mom and dad's
obligation is to take care of their
debts I mean if you give them ten
thousand dollars it's going to be more
difficult for you to make it through
school but I want you to make it through
school before you do anything and then I
would start talking about investing it
but the best investment that Ruben can
make is an investment into Ruben and
that's education to make sure you get on
through school is a big deal same thing
for your sister she does not need to buy
a car does she have a car now no she
currently doesn't have a car and you
know so yeah maybe a million five
thousand dollar car then yeah exactly
and the rest of it needs to go for her
to get into school and her to get her
education it's the best thing you can do
ten twenty years from now the way to ask
you to let me tell you what wealthy
people do they when they get ready to do
something with money they say what's the
smartest thing to do with this money and
when I look back on it 10 or 20 years
from now how am I going to feel that
tells you what's smart okay and so they
say well if I'm going to buy something
buy high-quality item that's going to
last and I'm going to get a bargain on
it and I'm going to invest in things
that last and education is one of those
now that's assuming you're studying
something that that is actually usable
the marketplace you got to study you
can't get a PhD in German polka history
all right I mean I mean you got you got
to really be learning something that
causes you to be able to win out there
but that that's what you know the best
money you guys can spend you and your
sister is on that and and that's really
what I'm going to push you guys towards
as hard as I possibly can and I'm sad
that your parents are even asking for
this money it should be used for your
all's future and for your education and
mom and dad all to clean up their own
ten thousand dollars worth of debt and
they should start doing that now
you